-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"
and the week that everyone wants
to go away.
Seriously,
can we just skip this week?
I mean, no one wants this week.
If 2020 was a week,
this would be it.
We don't want this week.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, we're almost there.
We made it to
the night before the election.
Seriously,
I haven't felt this stressed out
since literally every day
since March.
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
it's election eve,
and everyone is nervous.
President Trump's
gonna spend all night
waiting for Vladimir Putin
to come down the chimney.
[ Laughter ]
[ Russian accent ] Heh-heh-heh.
[ Normal voice ]
Seriously, I feel like
I'm at the very top
of a roller coaster,
and I know the guy in front
of me is going to throw up.
It's like...
[ Laughter ]
"Just brace yourself, man.
Ohh! Come on."
Yup, tomorrow, the only places
that'll be
more crowded than the polls
are liquor stores.
[ Laughter ]
"Three bottles of Tito's?
Yeah, that should
get me through the night."
[ Laughter ]
Here's how tense things are --
earlier today, I walked in on my
stress doll squeezing himself.
[ Laughter ]
"Someone's in here! Ohhh!"
"Someone's in here!"
A lot of people are --
across the country
are really stressed
about tomorrow's election,
but I saw this commercial
for something that can help.
Check it out.
-State of the world
got you down?
Want to release the tension
building inside of you?
Take your mind off your problems
with the Fidgey Whatsy!
The Fidgey Whatsy
is a new stress-relief toy
here just in time
for the election.
You can spin it.
You can squeeze it.
You can spin and squeeze it.
Uh, yeah, that's been happening.
We built these
for the amount of stress
people were having
two months ago,
not off-the-charts numbers
this week.
But don't worry --
that's why we started
selling them in packs of 20.
See how many you can break!
The Fidgey Whatsy --
for when you need to make
the next two days go fast.
-That's right.
[ Applause ]
I saw heading into tomorrow
that Trump leads
by 21 points among white voters
without a college degree.
In other words Trump is leading
with any voter
who attended Trump University.
[ Laughter ]
And this is big.
I saw that Biden leads Trump
among black voters
by a count of 87 to 5.
Hang on -- never mind.
That was actually the score
of yesterday's Chiefs/Jets game.
Never mind.
[ Audience groans ]
-Ohh!
-But listen to this --
Trump has apparently told people
that he's going to declare
victory tomorrow night
if it looks like he's ahead.
Trump said this isn't true.
He's gonna declare victory
if he's ahead or behind.
[ Light laughter ]
"It's close in Casper, Wyoming?
Release the balloons."
[ Laughter ]
It's like the guy on
"Man v. Food"
taking one bite
from a 30-foot burrito
and slapping his name
on the wall.
"I basically did it, right?
You don't --
You really want to see me
eat the whole -- Come on."
[ Laughter ]
What do you think
is going to happen?
The "Man v. Food" guy.
[ Laughter ]
At this point, the only thing
Trump can declare
without anyone questioning him
is bankruptcy.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Mm.
-Yep. Trump
told confidantes that,
if he's ahead on election night,
he's planning on
just declaring victory early.
I thought this was pretty
much unheard of,
but then I was watching
TV last night.
It turns out it's more common
than you think.
Check this out.
-Are you an older gentleman?
Are you running for president
in tightly contested race?
We know
what you're going through,
and we know
it might be embarrassing,
but you're not alone.
Premature election.
Because not everyone can raise
their polls.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, after his plan
to declare victory got out,
Trump denied it to reporters,
but check out when he said
about counting ballots.
-I think it's a terrible thing
when ballots can be collected
after an election.
I don't think it's fair
that we have to wait
a long period of time
after the election.
-So instead of the Biden/Harris
campaign bus,
Trump supporters will switch
to running mail trucks
off the road.
[ Laughter ]
It's always a good time
when your candidate says,
"As long as nobody counts the
ballots, the election is ours."
[ Laughter ]
But heading into tomorrow,
everybody's eyes on the polls,
especially in swing states.
Listen to this.
-In the critical
battleground states,
a poll from "The New York Times"
and Siena College
shows Biden leading Trump
in four key states --
up by 6 points in Arizona,
3 in Florida,
6 in Pennsylvania,
and 11 points in Wisconsin.
-At this point,
the best thing Biden can do
to win the election
is to lose his voice.
"Just don't say anything,
don't do anything, just --
don't put your glasses on
or take them off --
just don't do anything.
Get the corn dog away from him.
No corn dog!
No corn dog! No!"
[ Laughter ]
"Don't do it.
Just stay home."
It's like bringing a kid
into antique store.
"Don't touch anything.
Just don't touch anything.
I know it looks like it's --
just don't touch."
Of course, Trump is trying to do
whatever he can
to turn things around.
He's been holding rally after
rally across the country.
Check it out.
-14 states between
Saturday and today.
They are focused
on Pennsylvania.
-Trump will spend the entire day
on the road,
holding five rallies,
his final one --
late tonight in Michigan.
That's also where he held
his final rally back in 2016.
-Yep, he wants everything to be
the same as 2016.
That's why Trump spent
half the rally
doing the mannequin challenge.
[ Laughter ]
Let's talk about
the Democratic ticket.
Today, Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris
held their final campaign
events in Pennsylvania,
where they were joined
by some special guests.
-Joe Biden will be in Pittsburgh
today, accompanied by Lady Gaga.
Senator Kamala Harris be over in
Philadelphia with John Legend.
The Democrats obviously hoping
that some star power
will add some attention
to their campaign.
-Yeah, Lady Gaga in Pittsburgh
makes sense.
I mean,
her dresses have single-handedly
kept the steel industry
in business.
[ Laughter ]
Backstage, Biden was like,
"Say, did you ever tour with
a fella named Whistlin' Frank?"
[ Laughter ]
"Played the spoons."
Back in Washington, everyone is
on edge about tomorrow.
And at the White House,
they're beefing up security.
Look at this.
-Less than 24 hours
before the big day,
there is a non-scalable fence
expected to go back up
around the White House today.
-At this point,
I'm not sure if Trump's trying
to keep protesters out
or keep himself in.
[ Light laughter ]
Oh, and this is making
a lot of news.
At a rally last night
in Florida,
the crowd started chanting,
"Fire Fauci!"
And Trump had a very
interesting response.
Take a look.
[ Crowd chants "Fire Fauci "]
-Hmm.
[ Chanting continues ]
-Don't tell anybody,
but let me wait till
a little bit
after the election, please.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate the advice.
-Mm. In a few days, we might be
getting COVID updates
from Dr. Lil Wayne.
[ Laughter ]
The campaign has finally drawn
to a close.
And after hundreds of rallies,
I think this clip best sums up
Trump's closing argument
for why he believes
he deserves a second term.
♪♪
-If you're Italian,
do you happen to like
Christopher Columbus?
"Chris-to-for." Huh?
-What?!
♪♪
-How another one of Trump's
strongest closing arguments?
-Yeah.
♪♪
-You know why they're trying to
talk everybody out of voting?
People aren't buying it, CNN,
you dumb bastards.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Laughter continues ]
-Well, this is a big story.
The Biden campaign canceled
an event in Texas
after a pretty scary incident.
Watch this.
-A caravan
of President Trump supporters
surrounding a Biden/Harris bus.
The vehicles tried
to slow down the bus
and also run it off the road.
-Yeah, great.
That was my biggest complaint
about this year --
it wasn't quite "Mad Max"
enough.
[ Laughter ]
Well, speaking of driving,
check out what Hertz is doing
to help people vote.
-Hertz, meanwhile, is helping
people get the polls.
Starting today, as part
of its drive to vote program,
any customer who rents a car
for two or more days
will get a free rental day.
-Dollar Rental was planning
the same thing,
but, unfortunately,
all their cars
are "active crime scenes."
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Here's some news
from overseas.
[ Laughs ]
That joke's too real
for a couple of people.
"Yeah, that's scaring me."
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's some news from overseas.
Just came out
that Prince William
had the coronavirus
back in the spring.
Listen to this.
-Prince William, second in line
to the British throne,
tested positive
for coronavirus in April,
but, controversially, choosing
to keep his diagnosis a secret.
-Man, Prince William
must have gone crazy.
I mean, imagine being cooped up
in just 795 rooms.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-Here's some news that isn't
about the election or the virus.
A Canadian man sued Canada Dry
for making false claims.
Let's see how that went.
A B.C. man has won
a class-action lawsuit
against the makers
of Canada Dry Ginger Ale.
Victor Cardoso alleged
that the advertising slogan
"Made from Real Ginger"
was misleading
and the product
contained no ginger.
He was awarded $200,000, most
of which will go to legal fees.
-That's -- That's it.
I'm suing Mountain Dew
for not being made
from mountains or dew.
[ Laughter ]
"I thought this was organic!"
As soon as they heard that,
Dr Pepper started Googling
"How to quickly get
a medical degree."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, this is wild --
a train in the Netherlands
went through a safety barrier
and almost fell more
than 30 feet,
but it was saved by
a giant sculpture
of a whale tail called --
this is the name
of the sculpture --
"Saved by the Whale's Tail."
-What?
-Look at this photo.
Look at this thing.
-Whoa.
-I know it's in Europe,
but a broken train
teetering on a whale's tail
is basically
what America feels like today.